[Music]
thanks so much for coming tonight we're
we're so happy to have you here as
anyone who is here at the interval for
the very first time not even for an
event but the very first time in this
space your that's not true we got one
there one there any other all right
well fantastic welcome thank you listen
to out of applause for our four or five
so just to give you sounds like people
don't really need it but for for the
official record and maybe for some folks
listening in at home the interval is
open every day of the week from 10:00
a.m. to midnight and this is the
headquarters of the long now foundation
and also if we do say so ourselves a
pretty darn good bar and cafe that's
open to the public and one of the things
we do all right the public is well
represented Thank You public we're we we
have as I said you know we're open all
the time but these events a serious we
call conversations at the interval are
intended to be kind of a partner in a
compliment to the seminar series which
if you attended is a large a wonderful
event that we've been doing for 12 or 13
years now a monthly series of talks here
in this conversation series it's it's a
little more intimate and some of the the
same speakers with sort of a different
dynamic and I'm happy to say basically
every talk that we've done which is
numbering over 40 now have all been
sellout so we really appreciate your
being a part of that continuing that
streak tonight and tonight we're happy
to have another wonderful speaker Abby
Smith Rumsey whose new book we have on
sale in the back
and she will as our speakers always do
be staying around afterwards to sign
books to chat with you and answer more
questions if we don't get to them all on
the stage
Abby is a historian whose work has
spanned soviet-era archives through a
decade of working at the Library of
Congress and also consulting on how
institutions can best collect and curate
their digital data but she's also
looking ahead to the impacts of our
present-day technology not only their
direct effect on the future but how they
affect the perceptions of history please
give a big round of applause for Abby
Smith Ramsey thank you all very much for
coming and thank you for that wonderful
introduction tonight I want to talk
about the relationship between memory
human memory and the technologies we
create as memory technologies and I'm
doing so at this particular point of
inflexion which to me is very
interesting as a historian and that is
when storage of memory of cultural and
personal memory is going from the
default mode of print this thing the
heart of darkness I'm borrowing this
actually from the manual for
civilization and the default mode in the
future actually in the present is this
it's a digital now what is the lifespan
of this although it holds a lot more
than a book does its lifespan is
actually rather short or I should say
its battery life is actually rather
short whereas a book if I were to pick
up any book on those shelves up there in
a hundred years or five hundred years I
would be able to read them this once the
battery wore down I would not be able to
read and if I tried to open it and read
what was in here I wouldn't make any
sense of it so we're really talking
about a very different kind of a mat a
different kind of memory you know we
have a wonderful infrastructure in place
for managing our knowledge in the form
of physical objects and I know as
someone who's worked in archives and
libraries that the trick is if we manage
the physical objects and keep them
physically intact then in fact we think
we can keep the knowledge alive and
there
worked remarkably well overtime digital
technology is that doesn't make that
possible unfortunately well we have our
very ephemeral bits and bytes that decay
over time alarmingly and also are
dependent upon machines to encode and to
read and electrical grids and and really
reliable power supplies to give life
long life to these things and they're
not really passive they're actually
memory systems in the digital age or
actually servers that need to keep
spinning and require a lot of energy and
in fact a lot of air conditioning now
those of you who know the long now
foundation is I know the longfin now
foundation know that they define long
now as 10,000 years in the future and
the past 10,000 years and most of the
speakers who speak here and at their
other series curiously spend most of
their time talking about the next 10,000
years or the next 100 years when I is a
historian no there was very little we
can say about the next 100 years let
alone 10,000 years for sure on the other
hand we can say a lot about the last
10,000 years and actually it's quite
stunning how much more we know now than
we did a hundred years ago because of
the information the memory technologies
that were inventing now to mine material
evidence for information that we never
would have thought possible including
you know DNA forensic analysis so I want
to focus tonight on what we can learn
about the future by looking at the past
so I want to say that if you if you're
really interested in the next 10,000
years you have no better evidence to
look to than the past 10,000 years and
that's what I want to talk about tonight
know the story actually begins a lot
earlier than the long now it begins in
the long ago this is actually a this is
dates from about 40,000 years ago we
think and I'll talk a little bit more
about it but I think that memory
technologies and in fact the human
species really took a real pivotal turn
that moment sort of in the Garden of
Eden or at least it was a Garden of Eden
moment when we realized that we're going
to die
as far as we know there is no other
species that understands that they are
going to die not just that their own
partners or something dies their
children dies but that we anticipate
that we're going to die we know that and
I think that it changes everything
for the way humans think about time and
I want to talk a little bit more about
that but this is early evidence from
long ago about 40,000 years ago that
human beings from the very beginnings
became obsessed with cheating death in
fact and I look at this technology of
paint on cave walls as the earliest
concrete evidence of cheating death by
in fact extrapolating the contents of
our mental life our imagination or you
know our sort of spiritual life and
putting it in a safe place
actually we're outsourcing it to durable
physical objects and you can see it's
very familiar we don't know what these
people are telling us but we know that
they're human and we know that because
they actually signed their own piece of
art I think of this as the earliest kind
of it's a Paleolithic selfie in a way
you know what's so interesting is that
as a species we are not the strongest we
are not the fastest and we are not even
the brainiest I hate to say it but we
actually don't have the biggest brains
and we certainly don't live the longest
the one thing that we have is this
amazing thing that we have collectively
created which is our collective memory a
kind of collective brain which is a
thing that we keep alive over
generations which makes us able to
accumulate knowledge over time and
actually we are now at this juncture on
the planet when we are not only the
dominant species on the planet but
through our collective memory and
collective brain we are dangerously
dominant over the planet that's another
reason why I think this is a really
critical time for us you know the sense
that we have the certainty that we are
separate from other people that would
they're going to die and this collective
memory that we have have endowed us with
a couple of unique qualities from other
species we have a certain temporal depth
perception which is very deep very deep
into the future and very deep into the
past and through this temporal depth
perception we actually can
in mental time travel we can deduce what
happened in the past and we can project
that into the future we can we can
engage in conjectural thinking and
through language in fact we can engage
in what I think of as synchronized
mental time travel no better example is
that crew that eighteen or twenty years
ago started to put together the New
Horizons mission to Pluto and that team
and people cycled in and out of that
team at the JPL that team was engaged in
mental time travel synchronized for
astounding period of time and how they
ended up actually hitting their target
after that especially after the
appropriations scares they received
along the way from our friends in
Congress it's really a testimony to how
collective action and collective memory
really is a very powerful thing I think
because of the ephemerality of digital
technology we need to really focus on
ensuring that we have in fact this
collective memory into the future and we
need to reimagine memory when it's not
fixed when it's in fact even more
ephemeral than our wetware in our brain
I think that and I talked about this in
some depth in the book there are two
misperceptions people even very
brilliant people labor under that I
think are really going to keep us from
imagining memory the way we knew we need
to the first is this period of
information inflation that we're living
through is the people think that it's
created by computers and that it's the
first time in history that this has ever
happened this is a moment that's never
happened before
wrong on two counts every information
technology when it's new creates a kind
of vertigo in this case it's a digital
vertigo but as I'll show you there's
always a vertigo and the other
misconception we have is about memory
itself because memory is not data
storage memory in fact is some is a
biological feature of all creatures and
the first step in making robust memories
over time is to forget and the reason
that we have memory to begin with that
make nature has endowed all creatures
with it is because memory is not about
the past it is about the future if we
were born only with DNA
we'd all perish second or third day in
life and that's true even of amoebas so
with that I want to start with talking a
little bit about technology many of you
will recognize this is one of the first
and certainly the most durable
information technology that humans have
created it's a clay tablet also known as
a kunia form you know technology is a
tool that's created by human beings the
technologies have no powers of their own
they only have the powers that we endow
those technologies with and the
technology is especially around memory
are usually invented to solve a problem
or to meet some kind of a market demand
now about 5,000 years ago when the
scribes in Mesopotamia invented these
clay tablets what they were responding
to was the need to keep track of goods
and services in exchange or in storage
so they were basically accountants that
invented writing but within a relatively
short period of time a couple thousand
years I mean Sumerian time that's
relatively quick the technology began to
acquire lots of different capacities and
develop certain potentials in human
beings that were totally unanticipated
by the accountants another lesson for
technologists today if they think they
understand anything about the uses the
future uses of what they create in fact
what they came up with fairly quickly
and this tablet is about 2700 years old
is uses including prayers and omens if
you could actually read this you know I
just want to point out incidentally that
like the road rosetta stone this is
actually I legible it's a wonderful
technology we can still read it today
and if you did read a Cardian is anybody
in the audience read Akkadian good I'll
get no quizzes on what it says but I do
know that it's filled with divin ocean
and sort of a nation's about omens from
animals and human birth defects telling
us about what the future is going to be
so if you were to to be able to read
this you would know that in fact
cuneiforms were very quickly recruited
to do something that accountants never
dreamt about and the first recorded poem
that we have the
that Gilgamesh uses this technology and
as you may know Gilgamesh is actually an
epic about a man who wanted to become
immortal so very appropriate I'm going
to skip ahead to the next information
technology which is really interesting
when people invent new technologies it's
not in fact because they want to do
something new with it's very seldom that
they really do this is the Gutenberg
Bible it was created first case of
movable type actually was created in
Germany in the 1450s and the man who
invented this Johannes Gutenberg who was
a goldsmith actually was not meeting a
demand for a newfangled Bible what he
was meeting a demand for was this this
in fact is the giant Bible of Mainz what
are the masterpieces of hand scripture
it was done in the same town in exactly
the same decade the giant Bible of Mainz
and what Gutenberg wanted to do was to
create something that looked like this
but could be done much faster and be
sold much cheaper so the demand that he
was responding to actually was more of
this faster and cheaper it took a long
time for print technology to find lots
of other uses but it did I you won't be
surprised to know that in fact the first
people who showed up to really
domesticate print movable-type for new
purposes there are two types that always
show up with new information technology
the first group were pornographers no
surprise there was a lot of pornography
about the Pope and what he did in his
private chambers and other types of
depictions of human and bestial behavior
not surprising but the other type that
always show up are ideological fanatics
they're the ones that are you know
pushing against the the authorities that
control all the existing means of
communication and so the papacy took
about a hundred years to figure out how
to use print to fight the tech
sectarians who domesticated it within I
don't know a couple of decades Martin
Luther is the most famous but there were
many more many more who actually started
to build utopian
or we think of them as dystopian
societies like Boko Haram at the time
and I can tell you that as a historian
the communities that they put together
in Germany and in Italy and other places
have Boko Haram has nothing on them they
were actually quite horrific experiments
in utopias and they were all broadcast
through this technology of print pretty
much like the internet is used today to
recruit people
it also takes several generations of
being a blank negative in this case a
print negative to figure out to exhibit
some of the behaviors that technologies
always sort of unleash in humans I'm
showing a picture of Michel de menthe
end lived in the 16th century and he was
among the earliest print natives there
was no Michel de Montaigne as you may
know was an essayist a man whose works
are so wonderful that they are still in
print there's a beautiful volume of them
actually back there and the thing that
so intrigued me about Montana is that he
would not have been a writer if it
weren't for print he would have been
like all the other gentlemen of his age
writing letters to his family or
something but he never would have
published essays and printed them he
disingenuously said that he was writing
for his family so that they could
remember him when he was gone but if
that were the case he wouldn't have done
five or six different editions of his
works over time constantly updating them
in fact he was writing for time so he
not only you know print not only created
a new writer it created a total new
audience
a totally new audience of readers and
you know a new genre the essay and there
were many other genres as well you know
when people are confronted with new
information technologies there are
usually two camps that set up on the
frontiers of knowledge so to speak there
are those who look at the technology as
disruptive and very creative and
exciting and those are the sort of
techno optimists there are those who
look at the same technology and see
something destructive and really quite
horrific and those are the people the
sort of nostalgic sigh would say or the
the techno curmudgeons and in the book I
talk about quite a few very poignant
stories about people who had problems
adjusting to new technology or the
techno optimists who made spectacular
mistakes and thinking about what
technology was going to do to improve
the world you know no no point taken for
the 21st century of course but I want to
summarize some of that by quoting from
my favorite curmudgeon of technology the
sort of granddaddy of them all Socrates
and here I'm gonna quote Socrates about
the invention of writing which he
thought would lead to the death of
memory itself for this invention will
produce forgetfulness in the minds of
those who learn to use it because they
will not practice their memory their
trust in writing produced by external
characters which are no part of
themselves will discourage the use of
their own memory within them you sir
have invented an elixir not of memory
but of reminding and you offer your
pupils the appearance of wisdom not true
wisdom for they will read many things
without instruction and will therefore
seem to know many things when they are
for the most part ignorant and hard to
get along with since they are not wise
but only appear wise or as a friend one
would say they know where to look things
up in other words what you know
truthfully Socrates got it wrong it was
the cultures that adapted an adopted
writing that really moved ahead and
actually spread the sort of liberty of
reading to many people within and let's
note that Socrates who called himself an
ironist was in all things ironic in his
statement because he knew that Plato was
writing down everything that he said and
that if it weren't for writing we would
never know the Socrates had even existed
so he was wrong on many counts but I
guess he has the last laugh
I really love this quote though because
he was among the first people to point
out the moral hazard of outsourcing
something as intimate as our personal
memory and knowledge to objects outside
of ourselves and outside of our control
and that's really what he's really
talking about here he raises the moral
nature of the uses that we make of our
technologies and how every time we use a
tool to do something that we used to do
for ourselves we alienate a part of
ourselves from our own being and have to
take responsibility for how those things
are used I want to move on very quickly
to a moment
the Enlightenment this is Thomas
Jefferson who was one of the great
biblical maniac maniacs of all time and
he was someone who not only collected a
lot of books but was also he also
couldn't live without them in some ways
but his vision of books and libraries
was such that in fact he thought that
knowledge and this was true of all of
the founders he believed that knowledge
was going to be something that was truly
transformative and set people free and
so when he had his collection he and the
Library of Congress lost their
collection he sold it to them as a kind
of replacement and there's an example of
something that we can do actually
nowadays with technology he actually
took his private passion and wedded it
to the public purpose of greater
enlightenment I want to say also that a
funny thing happened on the way from the
Enlightenment to the 19th century but
one of the most important things that
changed is the what the use of knowledge
the way that we create knowledge really
changes I want to salute Otto over here
we have a drawing of Otto drawing by
Otto
I think of Otto this is actually a
depiction from a book in the 1490s about
the nature of knowledge and at that time
it was believed that these ventricles in
the brain one was for rias and one was
for imagination and one was from memory
and this idea of knowledge actually was
one that Thomas Jefferson embraced and
he actually organized his library
according to reason memory and
imagination but by the time he died in
1826 this view of the world and of the
arrangement of knowledge and how we
actually got knowledge was effectively
dead even though he didn't realize it
and that was because sometime at the end
of the 19th sorry the 18th century when
Jefferson was alive but without his
knowledge geologists began to understand
that the world is very old very very old
and it knows everything they discovered
in other words deep time and I want to
explain a little bit about that the
current information technology sorry the
current inflation in in information
doesn't really begin in the 1990s when
the web became commercially available
and accessible to anyone with Internet
connection it didn't begin with the
invention of computers in the you know
1940s by the military it really began in
the 1830s I mean I hate to say that it
began in one particular decade but you
can you can really see that everything
has changed because by then because of
the discoveries that rocks are clocks
for example that the earth is very old
all sorts of magical things began to
align themselves you know what we see is
a widespread abrade embrace of this idea
of materialism as a way of explaining
and understanding the world that's the
idea that everything that you see is the
material effect of a material cause no
more and no less and the earth in fact
is this huge archive the universe which
is at that time they didn't believe was
infinitely old but the universe is old
and it writes its own autobiography in
matter so by studying matter and
analyzing matter forensic ly you
actually learn about the history of the
earth and if you can do that you can
actually make very robust predictions
about how the earth will evolve over
time now this data visualization from
1841 is a very good example first of
what people did with information
overload there was so much information
coming in about the natural world that
cartographers had to actually invent new
ways of displaying data and this is what
you're seeing you can see a cutaway of
the earth it's very dynamic you can see
an array of all these exotic animals you
even see up in the corner above me above
the volcano evidence of extinctions
that's a dodo last sighted in 1691
people didn't understand there were
extinctions before this period of time
you know further to the point that
things really radically change in the
1830s it was in this time that Darwin
embarked on his you know his voyage
around the world the HMS Beagle with his
volumes of Charles Lyell's principles of
geology tucked under his arm another
volume that I saw volumes I saw here in
your library and which gave him several
hundreds of thousands of years in which
to work out his earliest theories about
natural selection if you have a lot of
time you can actually explain and fit in
a lot in the 18 innate
33 the word scientist was invented
before that there were only natural
philosophers who studied natural law and
there were natural historians who
observed the created earth it was only
with the invention of science scientists
that you had people using natural law to
interpret the evidence of the earth and
this combination really led to this
really amazing drive to acquire much
more information by inventing new
information technologies so in 1838 you
have the first photographic technology
the daguerreotype you have telegraphy
and railroads as well during this decade
by the 1860s you have the invention of
sound recordings and honestly by the
1890s you have this very uncanny
technology called an x-ray you actually
could take pictures of the bones lurking
inside of flesh and if you think that
didn't tell people that the world was
nothing like they thought you know you
were surprised it was really a shocking
thing to see mister dr. roentgens wife's
picture a picture of his wife's hand and
x-ray with a solid ring and solid bones
and this gray matter in between which we
know of as flesh so this idea gave a
completely new understanding of cause
and effect and the ability to see
patterns in the past and read patterns
into the future and it gives birth to
this thing I call the forensic
imagination it's the imagination that
actually drove Darwin
it certainly drove Freud to believe that
you could actually analyse someone's
illness by looking for traces memory
traces of past trauma through their
evident the evidence of dreams it
certainly fueled the imagination of
Arthur Conan Doyle when he created
Sherlock Holmes and it fuels the
imagination of people who are creating
the Large Hadron Collider today wanting
more and more data so with this massive
interest in data there was a massive
explosion actually in things that needed
to be stored on this although it looks
like a very nice old-fashioned library
actually this is a very radical building
this is in Paris it was started in 1838
to my point and finished in 1840 by all
real uh Bruce and it was totally infused
with
revolutionary theories that that got
Paris in an upper on the 18 in the 1840s
when they had their revolution you can
see that he was using the latest
technology which was a material which
was cast iron wit which allowed a lot of
space
it also [ __ ] fire so it was an T it
was a fire retardant and it also opened
up the space to a lot of windows and
exemplified the Enlightenment in fact it
was a whole new aesthetics a ssin of
knowledge this was a building that was
built for students they had no reading
rooms anywhere before this they used to
have to take books back to their
dormitories now they actually could come
to this public space and actually there
was an aesthetic visualization of what
knowledge was supposed to do and be for
them we don't really have that yet in
this world but it's quite fascinating
because we think it is so old-fashioned
when at the time it was read is totally
revolutionary and somewhat of an of an
affront to the well-heeled classes who
had their own private libraries so that
by the end of the 19th century we saw
this really big change and there are
four things I just want to mention since
it is an election year and I'm
addressing to this all the registered
voters in the room so what it took for
science and engineering to really take
off and produce the present time were
four things first I mentioned the
empirical methods and materialist
theories but also the harnessing by
economic systems to apply that knowledge
to create ever finer instruments to
create more knowledge that they could
apply more to the third was dedicated
resources to educating an expert
workforce which we certainly have seen
much of in the United States until
recently when there's been a faltering
of that commitment and last but not
least political regimes that are
dedicated to keeping the pursuit of
knowledge free from ideological
interference so all these things are
always at stake every election year and
at other times so where do we go from
here with all of this knowledge what
could possibly go wrong and I think
actually a lot and this is where I pivot
to neuroscience you know the brain has a
very
big job to do it has to acquire a lot of
information its bathed in this
environment of too much information all
the time and it uses very elaborate
unconscious elaborating and filtering
systems to filter out the short-term
memory from that of long-term it needs
to retain for a long time a word to the
wise it actually starts sifting a short
term from the long term during what we
know in vernacular terms as sleep and if
you don't sleep the brain actually has
no time to take the trash out and so you
start to accumulate a lot of trash in
your head and you are not able to form
long long-term memories so certainly one
of the mysteries of sleep is solved we
know that people sleep because it's
vital for making memories but if we
can't make memories then what is it what
happens to us if we can't hold onto
memories what happens to us and here I
tell the story of Iris Murdoch
you may recognize her she was a very
prolific writer and philosopher
and with a wild wild vision vivid
imagination and she succumbed eventually
to Alzheimer's you see her now she was
probably starting to succumb to
Alzheimer's already in this picture when
this picture was taken but people didn't
know it at the time and her stories told
very movingly in a memoir by her husband
in which he describes basically the the
disintegration of iris she yes she loses
her memory and yes she loses her spatial
orientation
you know the hippocampus that helps to
form memories is attacked it's at the
first organ that's attacked by
Alzheimer's and in fact it's actually
not the formation of memories but it's
the recall unit that's just been shown
by some scientists to actually be
attacked by Alzheimer's but the main
thing was that she lost her ability to
imagine anything because she had no
memory of how the world worked she
couldn't figure out what was she
supposed to do when she got out of bed
in the morning so this was an artist who
lost her imagination because she lost
her memory you know she really it really
proves that memory is in fact sorry that
imagination really is memory in the
future tense and that's why you know I
say that memory is really not about the
past it really is about the future
so memory losing memory is really bad
but also having too much is really bad
and here I want to talk I talked about
this but this man a very wonderful
soviet-era psychologist called Lauria
who had a very famous memory patient a
man called s we don't we know his last
name but I won't tell you what his name
is he was a patient so he doesn't get to
have a name he get he keeps his
anonymity but he was a man treated by
Lauria who apparently had the ability
sorry he had the ability to remember a
very great deal but he lacked what
Lauria called the art of forgetting and
I want to actually quote some of the
things that s and Lauria said you know s
was able to make a good living as a
minim honest he was a memory artist and
if he was able to amass a lot of
information committed on demand and then
recall it in performance but everyday
life was actually quite difficult for
him it was very distressing when he
acquired new information he put
everything into the save folder and
never anything into delete so after a
while his mind was really like this this
is what his memory palace ended up
looking like he couldn't consolidate any
of a short-term memory into long-term
memory and so he was incapable of
understanding narratives and of making
plants because odd as it sounds he
actually didn't know how life worked to
him it was literally just one damned
thing after another he said in here I'm
gonna quote s himself that he said at
one point I studied the stock market and
when I showed that I had a good memory
for prices on the exchange I became a
broker but it was just something I did
for a while to make a living as for real
life that's something else again
it took place in dreams not in reality
and Lauria says you know he had a fine
life a fine family a wonderful wife and
a son who was a success but this too he
perceived as through a haze indeed one
would be hard-put to say which was more
real for him the world of imagination in
which he lived or the world of reality
in which he was but a temporary guest
so clearly these are parables about our
collective memory if we lose our
collective memory at this juncture
moving from print to to digital if we
can't secure it into the future
we'll lose any sense of where we came
from we won't make sense of where we are
now and we will not be able to imagine
what is possible for us also if we keep
too much information around then we
won't be able to understand the true
value of things or to create a sense of
purpose because the true value of the
past is that it's the raw material of of
creating the future and biology tells us
that what is valuable is anything that
has a potential to be reused so we
actually can't make any a priori
judgments about what's going to be
useful in the future that's why we need
to be able to keep so much around
I just want to back up a little bit and
say this was kind of a cheap shot this
picture because it's actually it's very
moving to me because it's actually a
picture of a corridor of the Library of
Congress taken in 1897 when they're
moving into their new building
purpose-built building that massive
building you see right behind the
Capitol and these were actually some of
the copyright deposits that were being
transferred from storage into shelving
space nonetheless it's a nice picture
about what it means to actually manage
knowledge by managing physical objects
if you can't find it it's lost and
you've lost the knowledge anyway you
won't be surprised to know that within
ten years of moving into this building
they actually outgrew their space and
some of the beautiful courtyards that
have been designed by their architects
had to be filled in for stacks and they
built about 10 other buildings since to
hold their their stuff so with that note
I want to turn to now what do we do now
that we know that we need to keep
everything and it's quite difficult so
the first thing that we do is we need to
rescue the past from from its oblivion
we need to keep the artifacts as
artifacts because artefactual content is
is information itself the artifact
carries information but we also need to
make as widely accessible digitally as
possible and here I have on the screen
Carl Haber whom some of you may know is
an experimental physicist at the
Lawrence Berkeley Lab
working on the imaging technology at the
very core of the Large Hadron Collider
and he is someone who discovered that
there were there was a large cache of
early sound recordings that held by the
Smithsonian the Library of Congress and
others that were unplayable because as
you may know to playback analog equip
analog sound recordings you actually
destroy them as you play them back so he
wanted some non-contact playback and
lots of these materials were actually
broken or the wax cylinders were kind of
misshapen in fact and so we actually
made pictures digital pictures of the
recorded of the grooves and what you see
on the screen behind him is actually a
picture of sound so he's been able to
use a very high-tech technology built
too far to find the higgs-boson
to rescue the voice of Alexander Graham
Bell actually speaking for the very
first time into his recording device um
we also know that there are these
massive amounts of Mariners logbooks
excruciating detail about every wave
every bird every type of weather that
comes through on these ships the Royal
Naval Museum is stuffed with these
things and they're interesting for
maritime historians but now that they've
been scanned actually and they were a
massive database large eternal database
of retrospective data about
oceanographic and atmospheric
information they are a Fort Knox of
information for people studying climate
change so artefactual information reborn
digitally as data has untold no
knowledge is still to give us so we need
to convert these materials sooner rather
than later we also need to rescue the
present for the future and here you will
recognize brewster kahle sorry brewster
he's sitting in the front seat another
local hero who who has an exemplary kind
of archive the Internet Archive
technology allows people now to become
their own archivists what they're
lacking is in fact a robust backup
system but because of something like the
Internet Archive people are able to
identify what is valuable to them
and uploaded on to the archive to be
preserved
I say coyly it people are able to do
this on institutions like the Internet
Archive but I think many of us know that
the Internet Archive is unique and that
I think at least the real business of
libraries and archives is to replicate
something like the Internet Archive to
be able to make it possible to upload
people's memories as it were the things
that they value and preserve them for
the long term we can talk more about
that at the break or in in Q&A one last
thing I want to say about Thomas
Jefferson before I wind up is that one
of the things that's so instructive
about Jefferson library is that he
collected everything that he thought it
took to create the this new being the
American citizen and he thought it was
very important to have everything about
America but also to have everything that
recorded all the virtues and all the
vice of men and his book his libraries
were full of books with written by
people that he strenuously disagreed
with for example Hume he couldn't stand
Hume the Tory but he kept that because
he thought that people needed to be able
to know about everything that humans
thought and be able to judge for
themselves I want to say to me the
greatest threat to memory going forward
is that we would create in a knowledge
monoculture in which all the stuff that
we think is correct that we agree with
gets saved and I think we're real hazard
of doing this everyone can say yes this
would be true of China or you know the
Soviet Union when it gets reincarnated
in Russia that of course they want a
censor the past but I think we do a - in
our liberal democracy committed to
scientific knowledge trumping all other
kinds of knowledge that we only that we
always privilege some kinds of knowledge
over others and I just want to point out
to that to the wonderful biological
truth that there is no such thing as a
fixed perfect being that a being is the
one that adjusts most rapidly to a
changing environment so that mammals
they didn't evolve legs so they could
walk on earth they actually had these
wet linge leg like a
Tremont's these kind of you know mal
adaptations that when they were forced
to land on land they could actually
recruit to become legs and so they
survive these are called exaptation z--
and i think of that all the superseded
information that we have in our
libraries as these cultural acceptations
we all mourn the loss of the Library of
Alexandria but you know it wasn't lost
in war it was lost it was allowed to
perish because first the Christian
emperors and later the Islamic caliphate
decided that it was full of pagan
learning which had no value for the
future and so they had no interest in
keeping it around but without the
recovery the excavation of that
knowledge during the Renaissance and
Reformation we would not have what we
have today we certainly wouldn't have
rediscovered the Greeks and the Romans
we wouldn't understand democracy and we
certainly wouldn't have the foundational
foundations for scientific thinking that
we have so I think our own kind of
temporal chauvinism poses a very great
risk for us right now
are sort of intellectual arrogance that
because we're we're knowledgeable in
scientific about things that we actually
know more about the then those people in
the past we don't so the challenge for
us is to actually build a world in which
the digital has that same you know
really corporeal aesthetic experience
that this that people can understand
that this this library embodies but in
fact right now what we have is this so
how do we aestheticized this experience
I mean I look at long now and it's
attempt to help us think 10,000 years
ahead it's got a manual for civilization
that is in print format very enduring
and it probably talks a lot about analog
technologies for restarting restarting
civilization when certain things don't
pan out shall we say it has a rosetta
project which inscribes on very durable
form in a legible form information and
it also has a clock so why would a why
would a computer scientist who's into
faster faster faster actually same
that a clock a mechanical clock made out
of very durable materials is the best
symbol for the next 10,000 years I ask
you why that is it's because it is going
to last so I want to before turning to
questions I want to quote again a local
hero of mine a poet who wrote these
words in 1986 in Berkeley and I'm
quoting the last stanza he said I
imagine the earth when I am no more
nothing happens no loss it's still a
strange pageant women's dresses dewy
lilacs a song in the valley and yet the
books will be there on the shelves
Wellborn derived from people but from
radiance Heights those of course are the
words of chess off me wash who called
himself a poet of memory who lived in
exile from his native Poland and
actually in exile from his native
language polish who in fact kept himself
body and soul together all those years
of linguistic and political exile by
tending to his own memory using memory
and curating it over time to build and
to tell himself an autobiographical
narrative that told him that his life
disrupted as it had been was actually
very meaningful because something would
live beyond him and through that he had
some chance at some immortality you know
the immortality that all writers
actually dream of I think so this is the
challenge that I'll leave you with this
is not a Paleolithic
selfie but in Neolithic selfie it still
comes from not the long now of 10,000
years ago but the but the long ago of
12,000 years ago this is on a cave in
Patagonia and you can see that as soon
as people settled somewhere they wanted
to make their mark and so I wonder what
those of us who think about the next
town 10,000 years how will we think
about leaving something as durable as
this making it not just for the next
10,000 years but for the next 12,000
years and letting somebody who finds it
know that in fact it was created by
humans who wanted to say hello
so I thank you very much thank you thank
you Abby
do we have someone who can help out with
Q&A Mike thank you I'll take some
questions yeah and I'm gonna use the
advantage of my pole position here just
to ask you the first one actually so one
thing you touched on was that while it's
imperfect we have been able to recreate
and and bring back and find some of
those knowledge so I'm curious if
there's something to say about the
history of of meta studies in terms of
of how memory works or how learning
works and how and through history as
these early scientists we're curious
about everything certainly the way we
learned and the way we remembered so one
is there a history of that and things
that are important they're books that we
probably want to add to the manual for
civilization and second is there a
digital equivalent of that a type of
literature or study that's going on now
that can help with that or something
that there's a call for there you know
there's a lot of speculation about what
memory will look like and you know in
terms of what documents we need to keep
around and I'm not quite sure that's
what you're getting at but I do know
that one of the things at least that I
find the most interesting now about
thinking long term about memory is the
return of what I would call oral
cultural habits you know people
mistakenly think that the web somehow is
a library and they actually think of it
as they go on and they expect the same
kinds of privacy that you expect in a
public library where you know what you
search is not traced and things like
that I think in fact as many of you know
the world wide web was invented as a
bulletin board to be used by nuclear
physicists to communicate they had no
intention of making it into anything
permanent so I think we're making a
fundamental mistake that all of the
information that we
change regularly through
telecommunication has any has any claim
to permanence any more than telephones
did so I think there's a lot of work to
be done on trying to distinguish between
what really should be written and have a
long life that way and that which we
need to recognize simply as part of our
ongoing oral tradition which can be
continued orally like on Instagram or
something like that and just a quick one
when I mentioned it in passing briefly
but we do have some folks listening at
home we have long now members can tune
in to our interval talks live thanks to
some support from Edward Burtynsky and
his new film and throughout the scene so
a tip of the hat to them and and welcome
to folks on the stream who may be asking
questions as well but do we have any
questions in the room to get started how
about this first one right at the bar
zone yeah I was interested in your use
of s as a powerful for you know for
memory now for our cultural memory and
and it seemed that the issue there was
he remembered everything so he couldn't
extract the meaning but then I heard you
two suggesting that we should be
archiving everything so how do we make
sure we find the meaning or so our
future selves will find the meaning and
thinking backwards if we had a YouTube
of ancient Greece we'd know a lot about
food and clothing in ancient Greece but
would we find Socrates or Plato that's a
good question you know I I think that in
fact one of the things that's difficult
to just to hoist myself on my own petard
that I think it's difficult in trying to
imagine the future to use the past to
literally because we're used to actually
a system where very little ever got into
print to begin with so we're dealing
with an economy of real real scarcity
relative scarcity and now one of this
information abundance the other thing
that's quite difficult for me to imagine
hard as I try is that it's not people
who will be reading all this information
it's machines that will be reading the
information will be
the algorithms or whatever there will be
in order to set the machines to do this
reading for us but I'm really thinking
in terms of personal memory we can
actually curate our own personal memory
take responsibility for it our
genealogical you know we pass on to our
family things like that but we need to
be able to rely on the greater culture
to actually keep all the information
like government archives scientific data
that kinds of things those kinds of
things that we can feel safe that those
things are being saved and I really I
think we will not know until save fifty
or hundred years what kinds of
information will be useful and so we
need to err on the side of keeping too
much now I actually talked about this at
some technical level and that not too
technical in the book that we ought to
be saving as much data as we can at this
lowest level of curation so that in 50
years we won't have lots we won't have
discrete collections of heavily curated
information that we thought was cool
we'll have a lot of lowly low curation
data which will then afford people in
the future to make their own decisions
about what's really valuable because by
then they'll have really neat new
technologies to extract information and
see patterns that we can't even imagine
now your question right here on the
third row make sure to hold it really
close closer than you think you should
okay how's this you mentioned a number
of interesting points in your talk and
things that leap out to me are you
mentioned like this like putting
together this synthesizing of
information so my question is if part of
memory is really also in the recall and
maybe leading to imagination you know in
in the modern era we probably have more
of a glut of information perhaps we're
also just spending a lot more time
reacting to it than thinking about it or
we also do you have a sense that as a
society we're not as good at thinking
about it as reflecting you know that is
taking the time to actually think about
things that then people in the password
because because we are
overwhelmed by the glut of information
we just go from thing to thing to thing
without taking the time right well let
me say that I think we're actually going
through a phase which we have seen with
every innovation in technology which is
the first generation first couple
generations are really overwhelmed and
we many people in the room are are
growing up in this hybrid environment
you know born print and born print
natives moving into digital I think this
will persist for several for several
generations I think by the time you have
the second or third generation of just
born digital and the people who are now
growing up with digital technology have
gone through their lifecycle so they
have gone through multiple cycles of
Technology themselves and they are
living actually far longer than we're
gonna live they're gonna live in their
80s and 90s a hundred and beyond they've
had children and grandchildren and
great-grandchildren making fun of them
for their old-fashioned technologies
like Instagram that in fact it'll be
very different I mean I know that people
growing with technology this is an
anecdote this is not evidence but that
people growing up with the technologies
actually are already automatically
filtering a lot of it I actually and
there's a lot of evidence to show this
it's the generation that's caught in
between that are actually overwhelmed by
the information you know we respond
every time the phone rings we feel like
we've got to like do something with it
and in fact that's not the way people
are growing up so I really think it's
too soon to say but we're gonna get over
it we get over everything eventually so
right here on the front row it doesn't
sound like you're utopian but it does
sound like you're an optimist and title
of your book is when we are no more that
sounds pretty downer
can you help explain title well the
title really was a take-off on the poet
that actually stands at home that that I
read of Chesham he washe I imagine the
world I am no more and I don't think
it's a downer at all I mean I think the
truth is that most of us realize
actually when we're really young that
there will be a time when the world goes
on when we are no more what's going to
happen to us
some people don't care about that but a
lot of people care if not you know about
their not being around anymore what's
going to happen in the future and I will
say because we're among friends at long
now long now is trying to take actually
help us think about how to take
responsibility for the world when we are
no more because you know we're store now
or this dominant species who if we don't
care about what happens after our time
could really lead to a disaster a
die-off of innumerable things that
really sustain the planet so it's really
not about us and about when we are no
more it's about the you know making sure
there's a future for all of life on the
planet yeah and I'm not utopian I think
utopians I lived in the Soviet Union for
quite a while I'm very wary of people
who tell you that they are certain of
how the future is going to turn out
because they're the ones who can
manipulate people in the present in the
past so I'm very worried about that but
yes being a historian I think we're
extremely durable species and we've been
through much bigger harder much bigger
trouble than we are in now and we have
more awareness now than we've ever had
before
so the cultural fixes are there we just
need to embrace them so to follow up for
a second on your book tell us a little
more about why you wrote this book what
was what was compelling you to write
this book and by the end of it did you
say what you expected to say or did you
find some different things well I will I
confess that I started thinking about
this book in 1997 when I started
thinking quite literally about what was
going to happen you know when there were
no books as an historian and I was
working at the Library of Congress at
that time and nobody seemed to realize
what was happening except people in that
particular world and some technologists
but they didn't care about the future
actually but archivists did and at that
time with Bill Clinton's administration
the archives were actually National
Archives were being overwhelmed with
emails that were on these things you
know these floppy disks what were they
gonna do they had no technology to even
read them and I started in a spirit of
extraordinary pessimism to be honest I
had to answer that question what is
going to happen I'm happy to find out
that it took me forever to come up with
an
sir but during that time I actually
discovered that in fact technology can
solve a lot of our problems and people
are more aware of the problem existing
but the real drive for writing the book
and writing a book that is very short as
opposed to an exhaustive treatment of
the subject which was the first version
of the book I wrote is that it's really
the sense a kind of moral I wouldn't say
moral outrage but excitement let's say
I'm tired as a historian of people in my
own field as history and in the
technology world as treating
preservation as a technical issue that
people can geek out about but in fact is
just something that people who live
below the stairs should be doing it's
just infrastructure and the glamorous
stuff is creating data you know it's
engineering systems to create more data
because in fact I think that without the
past you have no future so it was really
out of that sense of trying to convince
people that the past if you care about
the future it makes the past more
valuable than ever and it seemed to me
in particular in Silicon Valley people
don't understand that necessarily and we
have there's a woman who's not in your
sightline who's been in the back or back
has had a quick hand raised great I'm
gonna make it an executive decision
we'll do two more I guess this is the
millennial question but so many of my
friends on Facebook and Instagram share
their lives is a super glamorous thing
you know the only things that we see or
them at parties having a good time how
are we going to preserve this sense of
alienation and isolation that we
sometimes feel and kind of our saddest
moments that you never see on social
media well I think you'll believe me
when you reach a certain age you will
realize that all of that you know you'll
take on certain responsibilities and so
will your cohort and I think you
actually sort of grow through a stage of
middle age which is you know one of the
most difficult stages in life when you
start to encounter in very real human
terms your own failings and you can't
escape them anymore and you're old
enough to know that there's just you
know you have to actually
with them and live through them which
are going to be going through this with
all those people that you know uploaded
those Instagram photos that look so
glamorous so you'll be surrounded by
other people going through the same
experience and I can't tell you how
you're going to deal with it because
that's actually what you got you're
going to create the solutions for that
yourself by living through it and I mean
I think it's an extraordinary privilege
that people have the Millennials that
they will be you know the the
Pathfinders for so many behaviors that
seem to become default after you know
after it you set that example people
will be coming along and we're finding
it but all I can say is you know you
will outgrow that phase and you'll move
it in the next phase and people will be
doing what many people my age do which
is use social media to share horror
stories and how we live through them
[Laughter]
that may be because we're out of that
you're out of the job market now and you
don't have to worry about that showing
up with a potential employer is there
are plenty of other generations have
those yes right
all right all right and now our last
question yeah so some what relates that
question I guess a lot of the data and
the memories that we're creating today
are being stored and moved around by
companies who provide those services for
free because it's compatible with a
commercial interest in advertising and
selling us things so can you speak to
the implications of that in the future
or maybe relate it to previous eras
information technologies yes I'm so glad
you mentioned that because it's I didn't
have time to talk about it but these
commercial companies that provide
information you know platforms for free
are a subject of well I wouldn't say
that they're the villain of the book but
I think that many people growing up in
fact many people who are grown up don't
understand that for free doesn't really
exist in the world and so and so they're
actually they're actually using you know
getting the data and using it in ways
that we actually do not know or if we
did we would not
so I actually I think there's a moment
coming up in the next 10 to 15 years
when excuse me despite you know American
politics there we will have to make
major policy decisions about copyrights
versus licensing who owns their own data
what uses can we use of data we're gonna
get better at actually anonymizing data
so that we actually have protocols for
non anonymizing medical data for example
and we can actually make major advances
in medicine by using this massive
corpora of anonymized medical data but I
think the things that we that we touch
on that I mean that you touched on about
platforms that control if not own our
data control our data or all things that
we need to settle sooner rather than
later because I know I don't think it's
realistic again as a historian no matter
what I want I don't think it's realistic
to think in the United States these
technology companies will be giving
stuff away or that we can turn to the
government to the part the public sector
to innovate in the way that is necessary
but I do think we need to put a lot of
you know governor's on the capitalists
who use our data for their purposes and
so I'm just waiting for time when we can
have a robust public policy debate about
this in the meantime I do everything I
can in the book to actually explain this
is the situation that most people find
themselves in you know we don't control
our email if we use Gmail Gmail controls
our our email so I mean notice the
things that many people don't quite
realize so I don't know how it'll be
solved but it will be solved you know
within the next 15 years I think happy
thank you so much for taking the time
thank y'all very much
I want to give you this long now
challenge going to thank you for joining
our conversation ice berries please
stick around please
the the books as I said is sailing on
the back and Abby will be here to answer
more questions and to sign your books
and thanks again for coming out to the
interval we hope to see you again soon
[Music]